[Musique]
la désertification a été causée
principalement par la formation de
sol qui est un sol fragile et par l'action de
principalement des hommes petits à moyens avec
qui font que le sol devient
beaucoup et je suis fatigué à cause du
la déforestation et à travers
[Musique]
Feu
avec la déforestation et les incendies
la personne perd le sol le sol est le principal
est le principal outil dont dispose le producteur
doit produire si le sol disparaît
à travers ces trous, voici le producteur
il n'y a pas moyen
[Musique]
produire
C'est nous qui l'avons fait parce que c'était ici
difficulté pour nous de donner de l'eau
À cette époque, nous n’avions pas de puits là-bas, n’est-ce pas ?
et puis nous avons réparé la machine et fait
ce barrage nous avons choisi ce point ici
et nous avons fait ce barrage
[Musique]
[Rire]
Nos terres sont faibles, n’est-ce pas ?
ils ne sont pas mauvais mais ils sont faibles. Cela dépend de
Nous dépendons fortement de l'eau pour
pouvoir
irriguer pour que nous ayons un
meilleure culture parce que nos hivers
ils sont très obsolètes, vous comprenez ? C'est pourquoi le
nous devons travailler avec l'irrigation
pour que nous puissions en avoir
[Musique]
chose